so you're calling for the logistics
industry to quote get its house in order
yes indeed we're still about 70 000 htv
drivers short we seem to have these
periodic challenges where we can't get
goods or fuel
to those who really need it and then the
government has to step in but government
can only put sticking plasters on there
so what we'd really like to see is the
industry given
a set of measures that they have to
carry out deliver more service stations
pay for the training of hgv drivers uh
that needs to be accompanied by reforms
in the planning process if the industry
then don't deliver those then that's
where i believe that the government
should step in deliver it and then put
the
tax back on to industry and i'm not
talking about the small haulers here i'm
talking about the parts of the supply
chain either at the beginning that tends
to be the big oil companies say or the
the end the sale part that tends to be
the online giants the retailers those
are where the profits are made and i
didn't think that's where we need to
look at the charging mechanism rather
than them just saying look it's nothing
to do with us um you know we just
contract i think the industry just needs
to get his entire house in order and i
think his levy would really focus
attention because we keep making these
recommendations that things need to be
done but they never are so i think by
putting a levy over the top of the
industry they'll really have the clock
ticking to deliver
what do you what do you think it says
about the industry that has taken a
global pandemic for these conditions to
come to light
well it's disappointing i think it's
really disappointing if you look at the
workforce as a whole so only one percent
of the workforce are female
and only three percent are under 25 and
that really just demonstrates that
younger people don't want to go into
this market anymore um for those that
are older it's been a way of life to
sleep above the cab but younger people
don't want to do that
the markets change they can take sort of
shorter routes
jobs so driving for
online deliveries um and women won't
work in the workforce because they don't
have the facilities they have to share
with the men well who's going to do that
um you know people need to be treated
with a lot more respect it's not just
about pay i should say it's about making
sure the facilities are there the
respects there the overnight stays are
safe and people don't feel threatened as
they do from crime
um it's just a systematic sea change
that's needed and i think the industry
as a whole
owns the supply of goods and then the
sale they need to own
the way that that supply occurs and the
shortcomings within it
okay um i want to talk to you now about
what's happening at our airport what is
happening at our airports queues
cancellations people are missing their
weddings their holidays are what's going
on
well what we've got is a perfect storm
where the market has really bounced back
faster perhaps than people that
anticipated
and the aviation sector just can't get
the staff in place fast enough
both because
staff are taking other jobs there are
1.2 million vacancies
and also links to this is because it can
take three months to security vet and
train the staff and of course some of
those staff just don't want to wait that
long they want to be earning so they're
not taking the jobs
i think it's disappointing for the
government to
appear to blame the industry this is an
industry that's lost billions they can't
just flick the switch on in anticipation
because there have been so many uh
changes to the rules
they've had to wait until there's
clarity and equally to say well actually
they've ramped up too much demand
parliament and government have told
industry if they don't
use 70 of the
flight slots then they'll lose them so
we've effectively told them to fly so i
think we need to find the solutions
between government and industry
to help the industry cope and make sure
that people's holiday experiences
are not spoiled it's not all airlines
it's just some virgin haven't cancelled
a single flight but uh clearly it's a
miserable experience for far too many do
you think they're going to be able to
sort everything out
by the summer holidays because it's
going to get worse than
before it even gets better
well no that will be a challenge i mean
one of the airports told me that they
are
needing 400
sort of ground
staff that have to be properly security
vetted
only 100 of those have been vetted it
takes such a long time i think that's
where we can see uh government and
industry work together so perhaps whilst
some of these security betting is going
on at the end of it um then the
classroom training can take place
perhaps we can also look at the numbers
of trainees and
the supervisors at the moment you have
to have one supervisor for three
trainees perhaps we can make it more to
the line of sight so i think there is
more that government can do with
industry but that's not going to happen
if they're both at each other's throats
as uh appears to be from this morning
okay mr merriman i want to talk to you
about the prime minister now in february
you said that he needed to ship up or
shape out and do you think it is now
time for him to step aside
no i don't and i think it's linked to
some of the issues we've just been
talking about the policy ideas that i'd
like to see put into practice which i
believe will help people and you can't
do that if you change the prime minister
because people just assume that it's
just one switch one change a bit like a
football manager being changed and then
a new person comes in runs the same team
plays the same match it doesn't work
like that with government everything
stops everyone changes policy gets held
up and we're we're at a really difficult
time for people right now not just on
their ability to take their holiday
or get goods transported as i've been
discussing but the cost of living crisis
that matters hugely to people and for
the sake of i think the most vulnerable
people that we represent we need to
focus on delivering policy change for
them and if you deliver regime change
then you can't get the policies through
that people rely on us for so my feeling
is that um he's wrong has occurred he's
apologized put his hands up for that i
judge people for what they do to turn
things around and i feel that he needs
to be given that time to do so
so you're definitely not putting a
letter in are you
i have definitely not as a lettering
and i will not be putting a letter in
because if i do that i'm then
responsible for
the very policy recommendations that
i've been making through my committee
not being delivered uh and so as far as
i'm concerned he yes has to be held to
the highest uh standards yes things have
gone wrong that shouldn't have gone
wrong but now i'll judge him on the
basis of what he does in terms of
delivering for the people that need us
the most you say people are worried
about the cost of living crisis do you
not think they're also worried about the
fact that his own ethics advisor is said
to be considering his position
over the pm's attitude to the
ministerial code and does that not worry
you
yes i i don't want to make light of the
the situation at all it does concern me
and i've spoken before about how
disappointing it is and the people that
set the rules uh follow the rules that's
the most important thing uh and we have
to ensure the ministerial code is
followed as well i've seen the exchanges
between the prime minister and
the his advisor
and yes of course it concerns me but
what concerns me even more than that
is finding fixes solutions to the
challenges that are causing people to
live
really challenging existences right now
and i just don't feel that we can
provide those solutions if we see the
prime minister change so i think it's
important the prime minister reflects on
what's occurred he said that he'll do so
and he'll do better we then judge him to
an even higher standard on that basis
but i'd like him to be given the time to
make those changes
so far 41 conservative mps have
expressed doubt in the pm's permission
position excuse me do you think there
will be a confidence vote next week
well i honestly don't know that there's
only one man that does and that's the
man that collects the letters and he
wouldn't be telling me so i don't know
how many people have put letters in i
don't know if there will therefore be be
a challenge but my point more perhaps my
appeals to colleagues
is that you know our constituents need
us right now and they need the
government to deliver and parliament to
deliver we're not going to be able to do
that if we are going through a
protracted leadership contest it just
changes all the focus all the direction
uh all of the chances we have of making
better changes in policy that will help
people
through difficult times
you can't have both so i think people
either focus on the theater
and want to change direction and i
respect their position if they do want
that but you can't then expect
government to be able to get on and
govern and deliver policy which is
ultimately the most important thing for
me so everyone will have their own views
to make i respect those that feel we've
had enough i just feel like we need to
change